bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
dans file echo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
il s'appelle anaëlle et cameron ils ont
18 et 17 ans et font dorénavant partie
des meilleurs apprentis de france il
travaille dans l'art de la table et du
service et ont été récompensés mercredi
au sénat
le réseau de crèches bébé bouquet sa
créatrice ariane rogalle ont été
récompensés du prix de l'entrepreneuse
nous découvrirons ce concept novateur
qui cherchent à aider les parents à ali
vie professionnelle et vie familiale
il le dossier la semaine est consacrée
au drive un nouveau mode d'achat qui se
développe en france et bien entendu dans
les yvelines et vous le verrez de plus
en plus de secteurs sont concernés
et puis nous retrouverons dans invité
philippe marguerite directeur de la
plateforme initiative à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonsoir vous
êtes accompagné de fabrice le loup
bonsoir vous êtes dirigeant de famille
link est une entreprise de services à la
personne qui a fait appel il ya quelques
années à initiative nous parlerons donc
de cette plateforme vous avez d'ailleurs
sorti cette semaine un site sur sur le
département l'occasion de faire le point
sur cette association avant cela on
passe aux informations économiques de la
semaine
meilleur apprenti de france un titre
dont rêve dont nombreux jeunes est une
réalité pour 4 yvelinois parmi eux
anaëlle et cameron tous deux ont réussi
ce prestigieux concours national nous
les avons suivis jusqu'au sénat pour
leur remise de prix un reportage réalisé
avec patrick jacq d'odyssud
c'est dans le somptueux décor de la
salle des conférences du sénat que les
meilleurs apprentis de france ont reçu
leurs récompenses de la cuisine à la
mode en passant par la prothèse dentaire
tous les secteurs étaient représentés
parmi ces jeunes prodiges anaëlle et
cameron porté les couleurs du
département des yvelines
leur spécialité l'art de la table et du
service quand on voit tous les meilleurs
ouvriers de france tous enfin tous les
cuisiniers avec le col bleu blanc rouge
qui viennent vous savez la main qui
viennent me parler et séraphin c'est
déjà ça c'est beau et puis c'est vrai
qu'on me suis
quand même assez magnifique quoi
impressionner ira vie ils ont reçu leur
diplôme et bien entendu la fameuse
médaille d'or du concours de meilleur
apprenti de france
est ce que ça fait d'avoir aussi c'est
un pur bonheur c'est ça fait énormément
plaisir pour obtenir cette médaille d'or
ils ont dû obtenir une note supérieure à
16 sur 20 aux sélections départementales
régionales et enfin à la finale
nationale une poignée seulement sont
récompensés dans chaque filière pour
arriver à un tel niveau il a fallu se
préparer un an et demi d'entraînement
avec leurs professeurs c'est lui qui a
repéré leur potentiel et leur principal
atout l'envi la passion parce qu'il a
fallu énormément de travail revenir
pendant les vacances travaillé pendant
ces jours de congé et puis une remise en
question perpétuelle
maintenant tu parce que parce que voilà
c'est jamais correct c'est jamais bon
c'est jamais parfait qu'il a fallu en
permanence travail et ils ont ces
qualités là beaucoup de travail et une
motivation mise à rude épreuve oui j'ai
failli abandonner un moment parce que
enfin c'est vrai qu'on enfin on rêve on
mange ma fond on rêve maaf etc donc
voila mais après faut persévérer et
franchement je regrette vraiment pas que
les professeurs m'ont poussé en avoir
parmi les épreuves la reconnaissance de
produits comme ici avec un plateau de
fromages juste derrière donc vous avez
le sens hector qui provient d'auvergne
les aussi une mise en place de tables
une argumentation commerciale une
démonstration de crêpes landais comme
ici je vais bientôt pouvoir flamber
comme ceux ci on présente bien comme ça
un petit peu dessus ou encore la
préparation d'un cocktail
donc c'est un cocktail qui est frappée
au tce coeur des épreuves qu'ils
retrouveront baccalauréat dans quelques
mois ce concours permet en tout cas de
mettre en lumière et de valoriser leurs
filières peu visible on n'est pas
seulement des porteurs d'assiette il ya
des connaissances à savoir sur les
fromages les vins des accords avec un
fer avec les plats
anaëlle rêve de concilier voyager
travail nous la retrouverons peut-être
sur des bateaux de croisière cameron
souhaiterait de son côté travailler dans
un grand palace leur nouveau titre
devrait leur permettre de réaliser leurs
rêves
nous vous en parlions dans fils
école-entreprise safran compte
s'implanter à châteaufort et à magny les
hameaux dès la fin 2014 il s'agira d'un
centre de recherche et de technologie
1500 salariés du groupe s'y installeront
et parmi eux deux nouvelles recrues
safran recherche actuellement 160
ingénieurs juniors et seniors le géant
aéronautique développera dans ce tout
nouveau centre de nouvelles technologies
pour les différentes activités du groupe
dans les domaines des systèmes avancés
aéronautique du numérique et enfin des
matériaux procédés et capteurs les
droits de mutation autrement dit les
frais de notaires ont augmenté de 0,7
pour cent ce lundi
depardon mais bonne nouvelle les
yvelines sont épargnés la loi de
finances de 2014 autorise en effet les
départements à augmenter les droits de
mutation de 3,8 à 4 5% deux tiers des
départements l'ont fait le but se
compenser l'augmentation des prestations
sociales les frais notaire donc passe en
général de 7 % pour un bien acheté sur
un logement ancien à 7 7% sauf je vous
le disais dans notre département une
décision du conseil général mais qui ne
promet pas pour autant que cette
décision soit définitive le portage
salarial prend de l'ampleur en france
mais aussi dans les yvelines à mi
janvier une nouvelle agence a ouvert ses
portes à montigny le bretonneux aux
promos paul alors tout d'abord de quoi
s'agit-il d'une nouvelle forme d'emploi
qui rappelle intérim puisqu'il s'agit
d'un accord tripartite lagence de
portage à pour salarier des cadres ou
des consultants qui travaille en
freelance mais qui ne souhaitent pas
être leur propre patron et monté leur
société
je vous propose d'écouter le directeur
de l'agencé rh solutions à montigny il
nous expliquait qui vient frapper à sa
porte je dirais que c'est plutôt des
particuliers qui sont qui sont en phase
de réflexion alors j'ai lu des cadres en
activité g
et des
des jeunes diplômés j'ai eu des jeunes
retraités qui s'interrogeait sur le fait
de se mettre indépendant un moment donné
c'est des personnes qui ont un savoir
faire qui veulent le valoriser et
si l'on parle par exemple des cadres en
activité c'est des gens qui à un moment
donné peut il gagner plus on est
indépendant et ces personnes qui ne
souhaitent pas forcément
subir les contraintes de la création
d'entreprise donc c'est vrai qu on crée
une entreprise vous avez un certain
nombre de risques vous devez mettre du
capital vous devez gérer la compta
les contraintes administratives
en portage salarial vous n'avez pas ces
contraintes est il gay regarde donc tous
les avantages du salariat ils doivent
seulement des marchés eux-mêmes les
entreprises l'avant lagence récupère de
son côté de 6 à 10% de la facture selon
un barème prédéfinis le prix de
l'entrepreneuse a été décerné fin
janvier au réseau de crèches bébé book
sous le haut patronage du ministère des
droits des femmes alors à quelques jours
de la journée de la femme sommes allés
rencontrer la créatrice de cette société
elle propose des places de crèches
disponibles en temps réel via une
plateforme web explications avec ce
reportage réalisé avec elodie moi non
faire garder son enfant peut parfois
relever du parcours du combattant selon
le gouvernement 63% des bambins de moins
de 3 ans sont gardés par leurs parents
trop souvent au détriment de leur
carrière professionnelle une société
yvelinoise à trouver une solution
innovante une plateforme web qui indique
en temps réel les places disponibles
dans son réseau de crèches de quoi
s'adapter aux nouveaux modes de vie des
parents les parents aujourd'hui en fait
on une façon de vivre qui est bien
différente qu'avant c'est à dire qu'à
travers le temps partiel le télétravail
les couples monoparentaux tout un tas de
choses qui fait que aujourd'hui on
cherche pas une place à temps plein en
accueil régulier mais plein de solutions
donc il faut aussi que derrière les
crèches puissent assouplir et recevoir
ses différents types d'accueil
trois formules sont proposées accueil
régulier à l'année halte-garderie et
même accueil d'urgence si la nourrice
est malade par exemple les parents
peuvent se tourner vers cette formule un
sms est alors envoyé aux crèches
partenaires des environs l'idée aider à
concilier vie familiale et vie
professionnelle les entreprises
financent en partie les places de ce
réseau l'initiative peut venir des loups
des parents qui effectue alors une
demande auprès de leur employeur en deux
ans la plateforme a réussi à convaincre
elle propose aujourd'hui 1700 places en
france disponibles en temps réel on a
commencé avec 150 crèches on est à 600
donc aujourd'hui on vise pour la fin
2014 je pense qu'on va être au delà des
700 800 crash août dans les yvelines on
compte une quarantaine de crèches
partenaires et bébé boucle ne compte pas
s'arrêter là la société espère devenir
la référence web en la matière elle
proposera dans quelques semaines le
premier annuaire de crèches ou les
utilisateurs pourront laisser des
commentaires
vous connaissez peut être déjà les
plateformes initiative il s'agit d'un
réseau qui accompagne et aide
financièrement des créateurs ou
repreneurs d'entreprises ils ont sorti
cette semaine un nouveau site internet
pour le territoire des civils l'occasion
de revenir sur leur activité sur ce
plateau nous retrouvons donc philippe
marguerite directeur de la plateforme à
saint quentin en yvelines et fabrice le
loup dirigeants de famille link qui a
fait appel en 2010 à initiative alors il
existe cinq plateformes dans département
où vous répartissez un peu le le
territoire vous avez deux ou trois
missions financement suivi parrainage
sur le financement ce sont des prêts
d'honneur alors de quoi s'agit-il
exactement un prix d'honneur c'est un
prêt qui est fait un entrepreneur ou une
personne qui souhaite créer son
entreprise
alors elle est faite à la personne etc
la personne elle même qui va amener cet
argent dans son entreprise et ce à
l'aide à avoir plus d'emprunts bancaires
ou de pouvoir accéder aux prêts
bancaires en améliorant ses fonds
propres ce qui l'amène lui-même les
caractéristiques ce sont des prêts à
taux zéro alors ce sont des prêts surfer
au chef d'entreprise et qui sont
effectivement sans intérêt
quasiment gratuit oui quasiment gratuit
alors le maximum que l'on puisse prêter
alors dans une plate forme classique
c'est 25000 euros par projet
alors 25000 euros pour la création mais
ça peut pour les projets de transmission
ou des projets de développement
d'entreprise ça peut monter jusqu'à 50
10 euros vous aider surtout des
ouïes pme tpe très clairement puis les
montants alors fabrice mais vous vous
avez obtenu justement un prêt d'honneur
en 2010 dix mille euros qu'est ce que ça
vous a permis qu'est ce que ça change eh
ben oui alors en fait donc au moment de
créer l'entreprise
on est venu la question du plan de
financement global donc je me suis
présenté à la maison de l'entreprise et
c'est là qu'on m'a parlé de cette
proposition le prêt d'honneur de façon à
renforcer mon plan de financement
j'apportais moi même un apport mais il
fallait un prêt bancaire et autres
marques concurrentes
voilà une légitimité supplémentaire le
prêt d'honneur me permettait d'aller
voir la banque de façon à faciliter des
démarches pour que la banque vous
fassent confiance alors justement le
ratio est assez important entre le prêt
d'honneur et le prêt bancaire ah oui
c'est de l'ordre de 6 c'est à dire quand
on prête 1
l'entrepreneur peut obtenir auprès de sa
banque que six et effectivement on n'est
pas là pour se substituer aux banques on
est là pour faciliter l'accès au crédit
bancaire c'est notre mission principale
cet argent alors cet argent vient des
collectivités territoriales vient de la
caisse des dépôts vient de
des entreprises privées aussi notamment
d'entreprises en cas de plan de
revitalisation
sur le territoire 50 ans nous avons
bénéficié notamment d'un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui nous ont financé alors
vous ne faites pas qu aider
financièrement vous avez également un
suivi et puis vous proposez des
parrainages vous-même fabrice ledoux
vous avez eu un parent alors pourquoi
vous à paris mais alors le parrain il
les attribue au moment du jury donc j'ai
eu un par un on s'est vus 2 à 3 fois de
façon à avoir un suivi et des points
d'étape
vis-à-vis effectivement du plan de
développement de l'entreprise donc moi
j'ai créé une entreprise qui appelle
famille ling service dans l'aide à
domicile
donc on est arrivé assez rapidement à un
certain nombre de salariés aujourd'hui
on est 33 donc c'est assez conséquent et
c'est important d'être accompagné pour
maîtriser des aspects comme la
trésorerie
d'autres aspects comme l' équilibre tous
les équilibres financiers et pour moi
c'était important effectivement d'avoir
d'avoir ce parent alors je vous propose
d'écouter un autre retour d'expérience
sur la reprise d'entreprise cette fois
hortense hamra dalle et la nouvelle
gérante de planet sushi à montigny le
bretonneux un restaurant qui est en
liquidation judiciaire ça fait
maintenant deux mois et demi qu'elle a
repris elle a obtenu un prêt de 25 6
mille euros et elle est toujours suivie
par la plateforme c'est ça qui est
encore très intéressant parce qu'il n'y
a pas seulement le pré en le financement
les anciens un suivi personnalisé
derrière pouvoir nous aider à bien bien
gérée à organiser les choses comme il le
faut parce qu'il suffit pas d'avoir les
soins au chant il suffit aussi de il
faut bien gérer grâce à aujourd'hui j'ai
pu maintenir plus beaucoup d'emplois de
jeu puis gardé beaucoup de personnel
alors elle a gardé du coup cinq
personnes qui ont donc gardé leur emploi
vous parliez vous de création de 33
postes est-ce qu'on ait une idée du
nombre d'emplois créés sur 2013 abbas en
2013 sur les yvelines c'est plus de 500
emplois qui ont été ou maintenus ou
créés l'exemple vous avez montré talent
à tout à l'heure planet sushi est un
excellent exemple une entreprise qui
avait déposé son bilan il y avait des
emplois qu'ils allaient disparaître il y
avait une activité qui allait
disparaître sur saint quentin en
yvelines et bien grâce à nous notamment
et bien cette ce commerce a pu se
maintenir on peut noter également que
les personnes aidées sont
majoritairement des personnes sans
emplois à ce sont 13 % oui enfin -
créent eux mêmes aussi leur à leur poste
alors on a ça dépend des plateformes
c'est vrai que par exemple nous cette
année on a fait quand même beaucoup de
transmissions d'entreprises on a financé
des transmissions d'entreprises ça
dépend des années mais on fait beaucoup
de créations
la plupart de nos je crois que sur saint
quentin on doit être à 60% sur la
création et puis
25% plus de 25% sur la transmission
cette année et puis un peu de
développement très majoritairement des
dans le secteur des services alors c'est
essentiellement dans les secteurs des
services s'est liée au tissu économique
local les services et commerces
on essaye d'avancer vers l'innovation
financer des projets innovants des
projets avec de potentiels de recherche
de développement très bien merci tous
les deux d'avoir été présent avec une
sortie au plateau et on invite donc du
coup tous les porteurs de projets à
cette fournée vers votre association est
je crois une bonne chose oui nous dit à
nous voir merci à vous on passe tout de
suite au dossier de la semaine
c'est un mode d'achat en pleine
expansion le drive c'est pratique qui
permet de venir retirer ses courses déjà
payé sur internet attire de plus en plus
de clients pressés en france on en
compte plus de 2500 et dans les yvelines
le concept semble aussi gagné du terrain
en reportage réalisé par ryan yolaine à
thorez pardon avec la collaboration de
la rédaction
nadine et frédéric sont des adeptes du
drive ils viennent ici chercher leurs
courses qu'ils ont déjà payé sur
internet en moins de cinq minutes ils
font le plein pour le mois résultat un
véritable gain de temps mais aussi plus
d'économies jettera deux mois dans les
rayons et je suis moi tenté quoi donc je
peux dépenser mon argent il je pense
économiser
20 25 euros par mois
à coignières ce service drive d'une
grande enseigne en vert en novembre
dernier dans cet entrepôt environ 7500
produits sont proposés c'est moins que
dans l'hypermarché situé à quelques
mètres car la surface n'est pas la même
l'entrepôt fait 1600 m² l'hypermarché
12000 ici on y vend surtout des produits
de consommation courante est l'une des
priorités c'est d'être efficace et
rapide
l'organisation est millimétré la
commande est pré découpés en fonction de
la zone donc on a grosso modo trois
quatre zones principales il veut gros
conditionnements qu'on vous qu'on ne
préparera qu'au moment de l'arrivée du
client une zone épicerie une zone
produits frais et une zone surgelés donc
ses commandes là sont préparés bien en
amont est par contre les produits
restent stockées jusqu'à l'arrivée du
client jusqu'à son identification sur la
borne dans l'est dans les congélateurs
ou dans les frigos dans le respect de la
chaîne du froid donc par exemple ici
vous avez des produits surgelés qui ont
été préparés en avance et restes
conservés dans les congélateurs ont un
titre que les autres produits qui ne
sont pas encore préparés
lorsque le client arrive à la borne il
peut y régler ses courses par carte
bleue et sa commande est enclenché les
salariés 40 au total la reçoivent
directement sur leur petit mais chez
nous on est parti
ça peut paraître long de la journée
par d'autres collègues on n'est pas des
balles en fait ce qui peut très bien
perdre à livraison ou la préparation
des coûts non pas sur tous les postes
bravo fruits légumes et produits frais
tels que la viande ou les oeufs sont
toujours présentés aux clients si
l'article ne lui convient pas il peut
alors le changer ou se faire rembourser
cette dame par exemple demande d'autres
poire ou un mur souvent dans les drives
tout est dans les sachets on n'a pas le
temps de vraiment de contrôle et donc la
moins on peut avoir avant de renaître à
la maison et se rendre compte que le
produit convient pas on peut faire la
demande de l'échangé tout de suite elle
se fera finalement rembourser le produit
habituellement cette cliente n'achète
pas tout au drive mais sélectionne un
certain type d'article des paletots
s'invitent eux
portait en fait autant de magasins et
puis des produits plutôt épicerie
produits secs et un peu de fruits et
légumes mais
c est plutôt rare préfère aller chez le
primeur acheter un autre et légumes
comme elle certains sont encore
réticents à acheter leurs fruits et
légumes en drive par conséquent d'après
le président de l'association ufc que
choisir de versailles le développement
des drive favorise les commerces de
proximité les personnes font des
commandes assez assez assez large de
produits et mais on peut oublier on veut
toujours oublié quelque chose ou des
produits frais et donc dans ces moments
là et on va au commerce de proximité
donc les petits commerces de proximité
évidemment se trouve indirectement
favorisé par exemple aidera chez ce
primeur de montigny le bretonneux
d'ailleurs on observe plus de clients le
samedi d'après le gérant cela pourrait
être lié au développement des drive car
en ce qui concerne les fruits et légumes
l'acheteur est plus exigeant ils ont
besoin de toucher leurs produits de les
voir aussi c'est important donc serein
de rêve on n'a pas de visibilité donc
sur le produit direction versailles ici
pas de grandes surfaces mais plutôt des
boutiques de luxe parmi elles sept
boutiques d'épicerie fine s'est mise
drive il ya près de neuf mois un service
plutôt rare dans ce domaine c'est un
souhait de notre part dans la mesure
vous ment tout cela pour gagner un peu
de temps disons pour résoudre des
problèmes de stationnement qui sont
quand même important pour chacun et
aussi mon yam 10 ans a service plus
résoudre les problèmes de stationnement
l'un des atouts majeurs du drive plus
besoin de tourner pendant des heures
philippe a commandé 48 heures avant par
téléphone et profite des places prévues
à cet effet pour venir chercher sa
commande en quelques minutes en ce qui
concerne le salé je pense qu'il ya 48
heures à peu près de détente c'est pour
ça que commande avant et puis vient le
chercher au quart
d'après les chiffres de l'association
ufc que choisir le département des
yvelines compte 32 drive parmi eux deux
modèles celui dit drive entrepôts comme
celui de coignières avec un stock dédié
uniquement au drive ils sont opposés à
ceux dits intégré avec picking dans les
grands magasins sur les 32 dénombrés
dans les yvelines -2 10 seraient de
véritables drive en entrepôt un nouveau
mode de consommation qui se développe de
plus en plus ces dernières années faire
gagner du temps un atout précieux le
gros avantage du drive c'est que vous
maîtrisez votre temps personnel ça vous
vous dites bon bah je passerai je sais
pas moi vendredi soir il n'y a pas
d'idée précise de voix c'est et puis oui
mais c'est sûr bon si vous pouvez pas
passer c'est pas grave les mythes c'est
pas d'ma perdu ou parce qu'un coup de
fil ou vous avez mail vous pu vous
passez lendemain tandis qu autrement si
vous faites livrer chez vous bah faut
être présent depuis ces trois dernières
années le drive semble gagner de plus en
plus d'enseignés se diversifie dans tous
les domaines à la ferme de grignon ils
s'y sont mis il y a un peu plus de deux
mois il avait déjà une boutique ouverte
sur la ferme mais les clients n'avaient
pas forcément le temps de s'y arrêter on
s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait plus de
26000 voiture qui passait tous les jours
en trajets domicile travail devant notre
ferme sans forcément s'arrêter et s'est
demandé pourquoi on s'est rendu compte
que les gens avaient pas forcément le
temps de faire toutes les fermes du coin
pour aller prendre leurs produits
fermiers et donc on s'est dit qu'il y
avait vraiment une demande que les gens
étaient demandeurs aujourd'hui de
produits locaux de produits de bonne
qualité et donc on a mis en place ce
drive pour leur permettre depuis chez
eux depuis le bureau de pouvoir
commander leurs produits et sans le
trajet du retour ça prend 30 secondes
devenir rattraper au camion le produit
qui est la commande qui est déjà tout
près de caen la firme espère doubler ses
commandes dans les six mois et si le
service se développe bien un poste à
temps plein le vendredi pourrait être
créé pour ce service le succès de ce
nouveau mode de consommation poussé
certaines grandes marques à multiplier
leurs la semaine prochaine j'ai
redécouvert la ferme grâce au drive
parce que j'habite pas loin mais je
prenais pas le temps de venir chercher
mes produits et là maintenant je viens
tous les vendredis pour autant le drive
ne signe pas la fin des courses en
grande surface car il ne reste pour
certains qu'un complément tous les
clients n'ont pas forcément une voiture
tous les clients sont pas forcément
adepte du paiement sur internet ou du la
pratique sur internet ça reste
aujourd'hui un complément mais qui va
généraliser on voit bien avec le
développement du commerce actuellement
vous achetez aujourd'hui quasiment tout
sur internet vous faire venir sa de
n'importe quel endroit du monde donc le
drive c'est tout à fait dans cette
logique dans cette logique là de
e-commerce un nouveau dispositif de
livraison débarque tout juste en france
le retrait des achats en ligne dans des
casiers réfrigérés et en libre service
si le drive séduit davantage les
habitants en zones de passage du
véhicule ce nouveau mode pourrait bien
être une réponse aux citadins des zones
piétonnes
et on finit avec l'agenda mardi prochain
le 11 mars la chambre de commerce
organise un atelier sur la création
d'entreprise si vous voulez connaître
les étapes pour concrétiser un projet de
création ou de reprise cet atelier fait
pour vous et il est gratuit c'est de
14h30 à 17h à la cci de versailles
et le 12 mars à un atelier à la cité des
métiers attrape comment rebondir et
bâtir son offre de services si vous avez
perdu votre emploi que vous sortez d'un
congé parental et vous souhaitez vous
repositionner sur le marché du travail
vous trouverez des conseils utiles cet
atelier se déroule de 10h à 11h30 pensez
à vous inscrire c'est la fin de ce fil
échos merci d'avoir été avec nous je
vous souhaite une bonne soirée et à la
semaine prochaine